das ist wirklich eine dramatische
entwicklung das große rätselraten um
beteigeuze geht weiter dieser riesen
stern im sternbild orion könnte direkt
in unserer kosmischen nachbarschaft
explodieren jetzt gibt es neuigkeiten zu
einer möglichen supernova us forscher
haben festgestellt dass das abnehmen des
riesensterns weiter voranschreitet und
der riesenstern hat sich dramatisch
aufgebläht klicks um science-fiction
gibt es täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nicht los
geht's herzlich willkommen das steht
fest wenn beteigeuze im sternbild orion
zu super nova wird dann wäre das
tatsächlich ein jahrhundert-ereignis und
außerdem auch ein äußerst
beeindruckendes naturphänomen
nachts wird es tagelang nicht mehr so
richtig dunkel werden wie sonst der über
riese würde bei einer supernova sogar
tagsüber von uns am himmel zu sehen sein
und nachts heller strahlen als der
vollmond kein wunder denn die explosion
würde in unserer direkten kosmischen
nachbarschaft stattfinden zumindest in
astronomischen dimensionen gesehen etwa
700 lichtjahre entfernt befindet sich
peter gosse und seine super nova wäre
die nächstgelegene die die menschheit je
mitbekommen hätte außerdem wäre es auch
die erste supernova in unserer
milchstraße seit mehr als 400 jahren
doch so klein die entfernung ist so
gewaltig ist der stern selbst der über
stern macht seinem namen alle ehre denn
er hat den tausendfachen durchmesser der
sonne
doch nicht nur das außerdem betreute
auch eine etwa 10.000 mal größere
leuchtkraft als die sonne doch seit
oktober des vergangenen jahres 2019
verliert der stern an helligkeit und das
heftig astronomie teams weltweit
spekulieren warum beteigeuze so schwach
leuchtet wie nie zuvor wir haben darüber
ausführlich bei pixum science fiction
berichtet gewöhnlich wird damit zu den
zehn hellsten sterne überhaupt gezählt
doch zwischen oktober und november des
vergangenen jahres landete beteigeuze
nur noch auf platz 21 und dieser trend
hat sich seit dem letzten herbst sofort
gesetz mittlerweile verfügt der
riesenstern nur noch über ein viertel
seiner ursprünglichen leuchtkraft auch
seine temperatur hat laut aktuellen
analysen um etwa 100 grad abgenommen es
handelt sich um den extremsten
helligkeitsverlust in den gesamten 50
jahren in denen beteigeuze
mittlerweile systematisch überwacht und
genau das führt forschungsteams weltweit
zu der annahme dass eine supernova
bevorsteht gemeint ist damit das sterben
des sterns und das bedeutet eine heftige
explosion so beenden rote überriesen ihr
vergleichsweise kurzes sternen leben es
handelt sich um riesige energiemengen
die dann freigesetzt würde innerhalb von
wenigen tagen wird die menge an energie
frei wie durch die sonne in ihrem
gesamten leben mehrere millionen jahre
hat der über riese jetzt energie dadurch
bezogen das atomkerne verschmolzen sind
doch jetzt könnte dieser nuklearer
brennstoff in seinem fusions ofen
aufgebraucht sein
die folge der stern kollabiert die
fusionsenergie kann nicht mehr gegen die
gravitation sich wehren und dabei wird
dann seine gesamte gashülle ins all
katapultiert das alles ist ein riesiges
entfernung in dessen zentrum sich dann
letztendlich ein neutronenstern oder
aber sogar ein schwarzes loch besonders
alles wird sogar noch jahrtausende
später folgen haben die gas setzen der
explosionswolke werden selbst in vielen
jahren noch mehrere millionen grad heiß
sein
die beiden us forscher etwa green an und
richard wasser tonic halten in einem
aktuellen bericht zwei szenarien für
möglich zum einen könnten gas ausstöße
dazu führen dass der stern verdeckt wird
und dunkler erscheint doch auch der
natürliche helligkeit zyklus von
beteigeuze kann zudem ab dem führen dann
sollte der tiefpunkt der helligkeit noch
in diesen tagen nämlich im januar oder
februar stattfinden wenn die leuchtkraft
des riesensterns dann nicht mehr zunimmt
handelt es sich nach ansicht der
fachleute um ein sehr starkes indiz für
eine bevorstehende explosion ihren
analysen zufolge schreitet die abdeckung
des riesensterns weiter voran
doch noch etwas haben die beiden us
wissenschaftler festgestellt die rate
der aktuellen helligkeits abnahme
verlangsamt sich hinzu kommt noch der
rückgang der temperatur um 100 kelvin
seit september 2009 außerdem auch die
ausdehnung seines radius von 9
der riesenstern hat sich immens
aufgebläht
das sind wirklich unglaubliche und
gigantische dinge die da in 700
lichtjahren entfernung passieren laut
der beiden us wissenschaftler kann dies
allerdings mit dem voranschreitenden
alter des sterns erklärt werden für eine
supernova allerdings
auch die gravitationswellen die kürzlich
gemessen wurden in expertenkreisen ist
die rede davon dass diese von den beiden
direktoren liege und bürger am 14 januar
2020 gemessen wurden zunächst war den
fachleuten auf sich gar nicht klar was
genau vor sich gegen handelt es sich um
eine supernova oder einen
gammastrahlenausbruch dem ereignis wurde
der titel es 200 114 f zugeordnet und
erste analysen ergaben dass sich das
ereignis grob in der region von
beteigeuze abgespielt haben muss ist
etwas mit beteigeuze passiert der
astrophysiker christopher barry
twitterte dazu in case you worry
beteigeuze ist der wettergott ist also
nicht explodiert später konnte dann auch
festgestellt werden dass sich der
riesenstern doch nicht exakt in der
region des ausbruchs befindet was die
gravitationswellen verursacht hat ist
weiter unklar
möglicherweise handelt es sich um einen
falschen alarm weiter unklar ist also
weiterhin wann beteigeuze explodierte ob
wir das überhaupt noch mitbekommen
fachleute gehen davon aus dass
prinzipiell eine supernova auch für uns
menschen auf der erde gefährlich werden
kann
denn die gammastrahlung die dabei
entsteht kann viele millionen menschen
töten
doch dafür müsste sich eine explosion in
einer entfernung von maximal zehn jahren
abspielen
der riesenstern nächste aber 700
lichtjahre entfernt also keine gefahr
dennoch könnte seine explosion das leben
auf der erde beeinträchtigen denn die
strahlung könnte die ozonschicht der
erde stören da diese uns aber vor zu
viel uv licht der sonne bewahrt würden
wir uns dann schneller als sonst einen
sonnenbrand einhandeln am schlimmsten
fall könnte das dann auch die krebsrate
in die höhe treiben die gefahr besteht
zudem das elektromagnetische signale
gestört würden und somit unsere gesamte
telekommunikation zusammenbricht doch
darüber welche folgen die supernova von
beteigeuze tatsächlich mit sich bringen
würde
da kann man bisher nur spekulieren
beteigeuze ein super riese am ende
seines lebens egis cosmos hat sich
intensiv mit der entwicklung dort
beschäftigt also anklicken anschauen und
egis kosmos unbedingt entdecken
niegelnagelneue kanal bei sn 1054 bis
dann bleibt dran